da consiglio diretto di uno di voi da
sotto i commenti dall ultimo reeplay
cioè dai giochi che vecchi belli che sto
riportando è uscito fuori questo che non
mi ricordavo neanche io mio ricordo
neanche l'esistenza
forse era meglio vediamo è un gioco
splendido uscito mille anni fa non è
vero milani fabiano però è uscito un bel
pò di tempo fa perché l'avevo fatto tipo
45 anni fa dove parte così io sono
questo vermicello a io devo muove anche
io che è perfetto devo muovermi questa è
una casa devo praticamente invadere il
pianeta terra oa come possiamo fare
questa cosa qua adesso da vermicello io
dovrei cercare qualcosa tipo troviamo
per poter andare sulla terraferma
io sono questo devo trasformarmi per
conquistare vai sulla rana vai alla rana
mi ha mangiato ottima
o sarò io a mangiarla rana mangiando le
cose io le assimilo e pian piano
guadagno se i loro poteri che divento
più grosso questa la trama di questo
gioco incredibile devo interagire
ovviamente anche con gli oggetti che ho
intorno tipo adesso posso pescare detto
anche dei poteri psichici posso muovere
le cose non schiacciarsi di meo che
adesso puoi pescare vai
ma come sono catapultati case volo
mangiarmi il pesce va dai a me
chissenefrega adesso sono arrivato a
casa c'è un gatto non so se mi conviene
tentare di api la pa ecco infatti lo
sapevo di non avere una porta andiamo su
ma che schifo al gatto è attirato dal
ragno e cosa succeda io posso non posso
mangiarmi il gatto sondare pro dentro
non puoi metterti in mezzo tra conquista
del mondo e me schifoso felino come la
madonna lo distratto sono fortissimo
andare avanti non ho mai capito come sto
facendo ma sono uscite di nuovo stato
no non puoi pensare di fare una roba
così
non guardate vi prego di non è family
friendly va vecchi sempre trovano un
bravo a questo è il potere che ho
assunto del gatto alla mia golino
simpatico permesso o anche le zampe
adesso a salve signora non si scopra che
poi è un casino
devo fare una terminazione nel mente che
distratta dalla spremiamo fare sta roba
così
[Musica]
che casino rega addio
poi viene volevo fare sta roba non
importa meglio meglio questo gioco
decisamente non è fiori frey ma anche
fighissimo dove lo ricordavo così figo
ma è premi towel punto c'è diventa il
cane non gliene frega niente di tutto
questo al cane va bene e posso entrare
la ventola del successo va bene la
indiana visitor let's go
quanta gente sta a casa maledizione
dov'è che sono ma va dentro
ok il pesce prima prima vittima
quello che non è che li mangio io io mi
faccio mangiare e poi milini di
distruggo quindi anche lui immagina
canarino è volato direttamente a nome
che faccio e destra dormendo e
facilissimo cioè in discendi
se sta roba qua magna dell'uccello
bagnato perfetto che schifo è un gioco
incredibile da qua a posso volare questo
è diventato è diventato il mio desiderio
numero 1 voglio inglobare le persone
quindi se mangio selena gomez diventa
una gnocca prova entra equa giorno è
cosa sono diventata una rana volante coi
denti quello sotto si sta cagando
addosso guardava faccio ricolo sotto
fuori
salve mi dispiace guardi non è per fare
favore a madonna giallo ecco questo si è
cagato addosso se non scorso nel bagno
altro io chiudo le porte tirò il cesso
ok questa storia sta diventando un po
off limits crater bazzi barba che è già
finito
cavolo mi sto divertendo va beh a questo
punto allora ci conviene giocare a the
visitor 2 the visitor richard c'è anche
il 2 perché ovviamente non ci fermiamo
col nostro massacro
vediamo che succede ma non parto
all'inizio sono di nuovo grosso come
prima immagino la persona nel senso la
intro mi rende fiero di essere un
videogiocatore la madonna è caduto
meteorite click the violent del cece
questo avevo già capito niente quindi
ripartiamo da zero porca vacca ho fatto
progressi
c'è un tasso a posso fare le cose bene
c'è una grafica anche migliore hanno
avuto più budget per questo perfetto ha
seccato software che è perfetto no
continua a cag arti sotto per favore
perché uno dovrebbe mettere il lucchetto
al cestino spiegami per quale motivo il
lucchetto al cestino non la capisco sta
cosa
io posso mangiarmi il tasso proprio
giorno però come un tasto non sa che ha
appena salvato il mondo ma è un tasso
questo ci sembra decisamente un tasso
eccolo qua al biologo buttar giù via
apriti o
cassino sto coso che fa centrarla dentro
posso mangiarmi l'immondizia spegne
prezzo è tornato il tasso che sei
maglioni conditio io ho dentro nel tasso
è boom faccio veramente schifo però la
mentalità da verme questo mi piace
next location un camper wow una roulotte
la donna una puzzola me lo sto facendo a
che schifo posso arrampicarmi sulle robe
che schifo ragazze dove siedono lava del
genere quanto mi farebbe schifo non
avete idea la legna la metti qua
dobbiamo appiccare il fuoco quello che
ho capito come sa piccià eccolo lì a
pisa lo eccolo là la legnano mi sarei
che serve il giornale no
apice ramo molto bene
metti a cuocere un bel coso con della
birra esploso la puzzola ma si leva di
torno
e io entro nella puzzola chiaramente che
schifo ciao
ma porca vacca a c'è anche questo da
fare
ok ma che schifo
vai a magna terragno va mai magnate lo
schifo raga ecco questo non è fa vj
friendly non diventare una roba
obrobriosa per favore no
ok il tuo massimo va bene sento massimo
te lo consento ma c'è ancora sistema di
difesa immagine delle puzzole no i
poteri magna talamo che schifo raga
mamma mia puoi entrare ma immagino che
sono più piccoli di prima però la prima
volta e mangia qualcosa di vento più
piccolo ragazzi che è faccenda brutta
c'è sempre un cane che ringhia poverino
mangiato uno scorcio ha chiesto tipo
avevano scorpione spiegano o sushi a
posso usare ancora la fila parte di fori
va bene non entra 90 dal tipo il cane lo
distraggono ok
posso mangiarmi il cane di fuori ma
vediamo cosa posso fare magari prendo le
salsicce riprenderli le donne ha
ovviamente beh non avevo dubbi i ragazzi
questa è la parte che farà più male a
tutti quanti perché era un cane
poverino e chissenefrega della puzza del
resto degli umani ma il cane non si
tocca teoricamente andiamoci a lui
all'amo torneo ninja hai salvato il
mondo sei bravissimo quindi come faccio
a mangiar meno è lui l'obiettivo finale
ma alcune sigle all'accendino ok vai dai
fuoco si è dato fuoco
vabbè poi sempre in saltargli addosso
adesso vai intanto lui fermo le cose gli
va a fuoco la casa ferri fermo come se
non fosse successo niente cui è
possibile ma fatti e le domande ma dio
mio
quella urlato c'è un'altra quindi grazie
avermi fatto capire che c'è una persona
no a sparava wow e tipo residenti voleva
ben tre vola fuori dalla finestra
teschio my friends el amador man forte
ai residenti volo questo stava giocando
a residenti vol
la birra adesso che la birra posso
entrare esatto eyefinity colpi a posso
decidere come farlo finire randomico dai
questo che schifo ragazzi cos'è non è
proprio fermi fredda che schifo vabbè
dai finiscila vertical pene non posso
leggere queste cose non le posso leggere
quindi ragazzi che sarà l'ultimo
visitors li ho giocati tutti e due molto
molto belli e molto molto istruttivi
scientifici giochi che ti insegnano
ragazzi come sono orgoglioso di me a
volte spero che vi sia piaciuto attenti
se girano vermi cose strane in casa sono
io che faccio
quindi occhi come se non se non dovete
mi piace anche la risorsa che come la
descrizione se non sei aversi discrete e
noi come sempre civile ad un prossimo
anno una prossima
ion e cose del genere beh ragazzi
[Musica]